Debbie wrong Michael Jackson's ex-wife
and the mother of two of his children
has lived a quiet life ever since their
marriage ended back in 1999 but now
debbie has been thrust back into the
spotlight after she was diagnosed with
breast cancer tonight
Debbie shares her courageous battle for
the first time on camera how hard has it
been dealing with the side effects
brutal brutal chemo does its best to
make you lose your femininity you lose
your hair you lose your eyelashes you
lose your eyebrows and what a lot of
people don't realize is it when I take
this off
I'm still me I'm still feminine I'm
still a woman and above all I'm still a
human Debbie received her diagnosis in
July and had a lumpectomy to remove the
tumor the 57 year old started losing her
hair after the first treatment what
happened was in the hospital I went to
move my gaze and it came out and I
thought this is really early cuz I was
told it wasn't until the third fourth
week that I would start to lose my hair
so I saw my hair in my hand then I
reached over here and there was more and
then I thought here we go I said get the
shears I'm not gonna wait for it to fall
out we do have the same yes I'll rub
yours if you read my
Debbie makes jokes it's her way of
staying positive and she also had this
blonde wig made she named it ursula
Debbie intentionally made the bangs long
to cover her eyebrows and eyelashes
which have all fallen out that's what
makes you look sick to me
eyelashes in the eyebrows when they go
away you have to work very hard to get
up every morning and do this how hard is
that hard and it's not that I haven't
cried but what am I gonna do I know I
had a choice of course with the bad also
comes the good and for Debbie the cancer
battle has helped her reconnect with
daughter Paris her 18 year old child
with Michael for a time Paris and Debbie
had drifted apart what does it mean to
you that Paris is here with you she's my
rock she's amazing
she's been with me the whole time first
phone call took her 30 seconds once she
found out she said
are you okay and I said yeah I got this
she said I know you do mom for her to
kiss my bolt that's love without limits
isn't it yeah how is your relationship
today awesome
if Michael was here today what do you
think he would do what'd he say
that's good woody I think it'd be really
really supportive yeah the road ahead
includes more chemo treatments and
continued radiation but Debbie's
optimistic mantra is I got this you do
have to stay strong through it because
if you let those moments get you down I
don't know if I could cover
Oh